(“Invito a los argentinos a sumarse a la
revolución liberal que va a hacer que en
35 años Argentina vuelva a
ser una potencia mundial.
Muchas gracias y ¡Viva la Libertad
Carajo! ¡Viva la Libertad Carajo!)
Dicen que si dudas pierdes, y que si
te ves perdiendo acabas perdiendo. Eso
al menos es algo que Milei parece
que tuvo claro desde muy pronto.
25:46 si yo entro en la segunda vuelta
25:49 el próximo presidente argentino soy yo
25:56 si paso el ballotage, en la
segunda vuelta les gano a todos)
Vale, en cierto modo, la grave crisis económica
que atraviesa la Argentina ha sido toda una
catapulta para sus aspiraciones políticas.
Al fin y al cabo hablamos primero de un tipo
que es economista de profesión y, segundo, de un
economista que tiene un plan de cambio radical y
que ha sabido como nadie señalar a quienes todos
buscan: los grandes culpables del mal argentino.
Las encuestas no dan lugar a la duda:
los argentinos están sedientos de cambio,
de cambios radicales que sean capaces de darle
la vuelta al país como si fuera un calcetín.
(“Hoy nos hemos puesto de pie
para decirle basta al modelo
de la decadencia. Hoy dimos el primer paso
para la reconstrucción de la Argentina”. )
Por eso, Javier Gerardo Milei ha dejado de
ser una utopía, una quimera, un candidato
imposible para convertirse en el gran favorito
para hacerse con la presidencia argentina.
En su carpeta está supuestamente el mayor programa
de reformas económicas y políticas
de toda la historia del país gaucho…
Y es mucho decir en unas elecciones donde todo,
absolutamente todo, gira en torno al dinero… Y,
también, en torno a la propia figura de Javier
Milei. ¿Queréis una prueba? Pues… Vosotros mismos.
N1 (7 sep 2023: Massa, contra Milei:
“Propone ajuste y devaluación,
lo disfraza con la dolarización”. La Nación)
N2 (31 agos 2023: Junto a Bullrich, Melconian
señaló que su plan económico “está listo para
desembarcar”. Con referencias
indirectas hacia Javier Milei,
el economista aseguró que cuenta con un plan
“realista e implementable” y que no representa
“un salto al vacío”
Bloomberg)
¿Qué os voy a contar? La dolarización ha
marcado la agenda electoral como nunca
antes. Hoy por hoy esta promesa se ha
convertido en el gran sueño del cambio:
Que la desaparición definitiva del Peso ayude
a la Argentina a escapar de las tinieblas.
Por supuesto, esa no es su única promesa
de corte económico. Milei también ha
prometido una drástica reducción del gasto
público, muchas menos regulaciones y una
agresiva liberalización comercial. Junto a la
dolarización, estas 3 ideas se han convertido
en el gran comodín de un candidato al
que ya muchos ven en la Casa Rosada.
Puede resultar sorprendente visto desde fuera
de la Argentina, pero hoy en el país gaucho
el plan de Milei levanta tanta pasión y
tantas controversias como si se tratara
de un auténtico debate futbolístico
entre hinchas del Boca y del River.
Claro que en un país donde la inflación
supera el 120% lo raro es que el dinero,
la economía y el futuro del peso no
fueran los grandes temas del momento.
¿Qué importa todo lo demás si lo que está
en juego es el pan que llevarse a la boca?
Claro que de todo esto ya se ha
hablado y mucho. Por eso la pregunta,
la gran pregunta que nos
heEmos hecho, es muy clara:
¿Qué hay realmente en la agenda de Milei más
allá de los grandes números y la economía?
¿Cuáles son sus planes - si es que los hay
- en terrenos como las infraestructuras,
la salud o la educación? ¿Cómo piensa
abordar exactamente la transición política
que conllevaría su enorme hoja de
ruta? Al margen de lo económico,
¿qué tanto se diferencia Milei del
resto de la oposición al peronismo?
Pues… Todo esto y más lo
vamos a ver a continuación.
¡Arranquemos!
(T1: SALUD Y EDUCACIÓN: CAMBIO
LENTO, PERO ¿CAMBIO SEGURO?)
Vale, creo que todos lo tenemos más o menos claro:
el plan de Milei - al menos por ahora - contempla
una enorme ola de transformación de
la república argentina… O mejor dicho,
del estado argentino… Lo que en el país
gaucho viene a ser prácticamente lo mismo.
En este sentido, Salud y Educación
dejarán de ser ministerios para
convertirse en Secretarías dentro
de un macro ministerio de Capital
Humano que coordine todas las acciones que
tengan que ver con la asistencia social.
[Sí, lo habéis pillado, esta es una de
esas tretas que consisten en reducir
unos organismos para crear otros y
al final seguir más o menos igual.]
Así que pasemos de esta cuestión y
vayamos directamente a lo importante.
Lo que propone Milei es esencialmente
un nuevo modelo de financiación,
donde el gobierno subvencione la
demanda y no directamente la oferta.
(15:04 También queremos dejar claro que nuestra
15:07 visión el mejor sistema de salud posible
15:10 es un sistema de salud privado donde
15:12 cada argentino pague sus servicios. El
15:15 mejor sistema educativo posible es uno
15:17 donde cada argentino pague por sus
15:19 servicios. Esto es así. No es debatible.)
Es decir, que la educación y la sanidad sigan
siendo mayormente servicios “gratuitos” para los
argentinos, pero que estos puedan elegir el centro
que les provea estos servicios. El objetivo sería
que poco a poco fuera surgiendo un mercado cada
vez más competitivo y cada vez con más oferentes.
Sin embargo, hay un pequeño inconveniente:
incluso más allá del reto que
supondría ligar la financiación
de los centros públicos a la demanda,
en el sistema argentino, tanto la salud
como la educación no universitaria
están en manos de las provincias.
Es decir, que el cambio para ser
siquiera posible tendría que ser
todavía más grande… ¿Y sabéis qué? Esto
es lo que explica el gradualismo que
manifiestan los propios referentes
de Milei sobre estos temas. Fijaos.
C1 (“Los subsistemas públicos, privados
y de la seguridad social seguirán. Los
hospitales seguirán funcionando igual,
pero tendrán que hacerlo con una mejor
gestión. Lo harán en cada distrito
y como lo decida cada jurisdicción,
pero con la universalización de la cobertura
(que todo el mundo tenga un seguro y con
prestaciones posibles). Eduardo Filgueira Lima –
Referente de políticas de salud de Javier Milei)
De esta forma, a nivel de salud, Milei se
ha comprometido instaurar un seguro médico
universal que fuese financiado por el estado,
ese sería el primer paso. Luego poco a poco la
financiación de los centros iría dependiendo
del nivel de demanda de cada centro, lo que
les obligaría a competir entre sí aunque fueran
centros públicos. Claro que habría que ver qué
incentivos tendrían a competir… Lo lógico es que
un nivel de demanda mayor en un centro supusiera
salarios más altos para sus profesionales…
Pero hablamos de Argentina, no parece fácil.
Luego en educación los equipos de la Libertad
Avanza plantean iniciativas similares.
C2 (“La entrega del voucher podría hacerse
por medio de una tarjeta, con una cuenta,
como las Educational Savings Accounts
(ESA), que funcionan en algunos estados
de Estados Unidos. Con esa tarjeta, el
estudiante paga la cuota de un colegio,
público o privado (…) Se buscaría llegar
a algún acuerdo con alguna provincia que
esté dispuesta a avanzar en la reforma. De
paso serviría de ejemplo hacia las demás,
las que tal vez luego querrían avanzar
en ese sentido”. Martín Krause)
El problema, como veis, es que aquí vuelven
a surgir las provincias… Sin las
provincias no hay nada que hacer.
(Luego, más allá de estos grandes cambios
estructurales, los planes de Milei también
contemplan otras reformas de menor calibre,
como, por ejemplo, una reforma de la Ley de
Educación, que permita hacer públicos los
resultados de las pruebas de desempeño,
tanto de alumnos como de maestros, de todos
los establecimientos educativos. Es decir,
introducir evaluaciones realmente efectivas
que influyan en la búsqueda de centros.)
En cualquier caso, ya lo veis. Más allá de los
grandes titulares, no está claro que a corto y
medio plazo los planes de Milei supusieran
muchos cambios. Los cheques educativos y
de salud pueden ser una gran idea… Pero no está
claro que puedan tener grandes efectos reales. El
riesgo es que cualquier cambio que pueda tocar los
salarios de los empleados públicos termine como
el rosario de la aurora y que de no hacerlo
la medida no sirva para prácticamente nada.
Claro que esto es tan solo el comienzo.
(T2. ¿EL DEBATE DE LA SEGURIDAD?)
Durante el gobierno de Alberto Fernández, no se
puede decir que la vicepresidencia haya tenido
un rol precisamente irrelevante.
A cargo de Cristina Fernández de
Kirchner la Vicepresidencia tuvo por momentos
muchísima visibilidad y muchísima influencia,
hasta el punto de desatar una feroz
guerra interna dentro del oficialismo.
Es decir, que ahora la vicepresidencia se percibe
como un órgano mucho más relevante de
cómo se veía hace apenas unos pocos años.
Pues bien, en este sentido, Javier Milei optó por
Victoria Villarruel como compañera de fórmula.
A ella le ha encomendado, además, la gestión de
todos los temas relativos a seguridad y defensa.
Argentina, amigos, ha sido y sigue siendo
un país relativamente seguro, al menos para
los cánones que se manejan en América Latina.
Pese a ello, en los últimos años los tentáculos
del narcotráfico se están extendiendo
por todo el país y en general por todo
el cono sur. Este será sin duda uno de
los grandes retos del nuevo gobierno.
N3 (Argentina busca reforzar la justicia contra la
escalada de violencia narco en Rosario. El País)
N4 (Lucha contra el narcotráfico: Uruguay
y Paraguay refuerzan los controles en sus
puertos tras las medidas que
implementó Argentina. InfoBae)
En este escenario la Libertad
Avanza tiene varias propuestas,
algunas de ellas tan polémicas como esta:
C3 (“Sobre la tenencia de armas de
fuego planteamos la desregulación
del mercado legal y proteger su
uso legítimo y responsable por
parte de la ciudadanía.” Plataforma
Electoral – La Libertad Avanza (2023)
Claro que con el tiempo sobre esta cuestión en
particular han surgido algunas contradicciones..
(27:16 se ve con claridad o sea
los lugares donde la gente anda
calzada (armada) la delincuencia es menor
27:23 osea, ¿estas a favor de que
la gente se arme?
27:25 si, ¿por qué no?
27:27 el mercado de armas, ¿lo liberarías?
27:29 sí)
(0:20 por ejemplo la aportación de arma que es
0:22 un tema que usted instaló en la campaña
0:23 ¿lo va a implementar pronto?
yo no la instalé en la campaña ni
0:26 siquiera está en la plataforma no está
0:28 en la plataforma)
Luego, el tema de la libre portación de armas fue
desplazado de la agenda libertaria, al tiempo que
Villarruel se ha posicionado como la exponente
de una nueva doctrina de seguridad denominada
“El que las hace las paga”... Una reforma que
alcanza a la ley de seguridad interior, a la ley
de defensa nacional y a la ley de inteligencia.
(3:09 Vamos a reforzar el esfuerzo de la Policía
3:13 Nacional respaldando las acciones de las
3:16 fuerzas del orden potenciando el Consejo
3:19 de Seguridad interior. Además de que
3:22 vamos a recurrir a la figura del comité
3:24 de crisis que está estipulada para las
3:27 emergencias en la ley
de seguridad
3:29 interior)
La idea con la que trabaja el equipo de
Milei pasa por endurecer las penas y los
márgenes de actuación de las fuerzas de seguridad,
mientras que en lo que respecta a las cárceles,
se plantea la construcción de nuevas
prisiones de gestión público-privada
donde los reclusos puedan incluso
participar en jornadas laborales.
Claro que… En cuestión de seguridad, el plan de la
Libertad Avanza no solo tiene grandes similitudes,
sino que va, incluso, en desventaja en comparación
con la candidatura de Patricia Bullrich.
Bullrich ejerció como ministra de Seguridad de
Mauricio Macri entre 2015 y 2019, y en cierta
forma puso en práctica buena parte del cambio de
paradigma y las reformas a las que ahora apunta
Villarruel, lo que, lógicamente, le da una cierta
ventaja, aunque solo sea por tener más experiencia
en el campo:
(VIDEO 7)
(2:59 los Derechos Humanos
son para los delincuentes
3:02 las leyes son para las
delincuentes, el código penal actual
3:07 que nosotros lo quisimos
cambiar y no lo permitieron
3:10 son para los delincuentes
+
3:19 es decir protegen
permanentemente a los delincuentes y
3:21 desprotegen a los ciudadanos y lo peor
3:25 de todo desprotegen a quienes nos cuidan)
Sea como sea, las estrategias
planteadas en materia de seguridad,
salud y educación mantienen una
línea más o menos coherente.
Y digo esto porque luego en el resto de
propuestas podemos encontrar posiciones mucho más
heterogéneas… Que en algunos casos, para muchos,
escapan incluso de las fronteras liberales.
¿Está sufriendo el león sabotajes
dentro de casa? Pues… Atentos.
(T3: ¿INFILTRACIÓN DE “LA
CASTA” O TEOREMA DE BAGLINI?)
Queridos amigos, amigas, digamos
que, a principios de este 2023,
el perfil político de Javier Milei no era tan
atractivo como lo puede ser hoy para todos
aquellos profesionales y referentes políticos
que buscaban alguna plataforma a la cual unirse.
Y eso, eso fue algo que de alguna
forma provocó un batiburrillo,
un conglomerado de perfiles muy heterogéneos que
se fueron sumando a La Libertad Avanza. Que es,
exactamente lo que explica noticias como estas:
N5 (Renunció una funcionaria de Axel Kicillof
(Gobernador peronista) que es candidata de
Javier Milei. La candidata también figura en
el organigrama del gobierno bonaerense como
directora de Servicios Auxiliares del Ministerio
de Transporte de la provincia de Buenos Aires,
cartera del gobierno de Axel Kicillof
que está a cargo de Rodolfo D’Onofrio,
un hombre de Sergio Massa. La Nacion)
N6 (Quién es Miguel Ángel Ponte,
el ex funcionario macrista que
podría ser secretario de Trabajo si
Javier Milei es Presidente. InfoBae)
N7 (Grabois aseguró que Milei armó las
listas "con toda gente de Massa". El ex
precandidato presidencial de Unión
por la Patria (UP), Juan Grabois,
sostuvo en las últimas horas que Javier Milei
logró armar las listas en todo el país “con toda
gente de Massa”. “No me cabe la menor duda que
no son enemigos acérrimos”, sostuvo. La gaceta)
Este tipo de situaciones han generado algunas
contradicciones y también algunas dudas sobre
las intenciones del candidato en relación con
los sindicatos o una eventual reforma laboral.
Por ejemplo, el programa de la plataforma de Milei
propone eliminar las indemnizaciones por
despido o reformar de arriba abajo los
sindicatos. Claro que ahora estas cosas
son descartadas por el propio Milei.
(0:40 Será una cuestión que tendrán
0:44 que resolver ellos internamente,
de cómo
0:46 por qué
esto funciona así … *periodista* ¿Pero no te
0:48 parece algo que hay que también romper?
0:51 Pero de vuelta eso es un
0:52 problema que tienen que resolver los
0:54 sindicalistas, digo, no tengo por qué
0:55 estar rompiendo yo una institución)
El problema es que no es ningún secreto que los
sindicatos en Argentina son una institución con
enorme poder, capaz de paralizar cualquier
aparato productivo de forma casi indefinida,
por lo que este cambio de rumbo
quizás no resulta tan inesperado:
N8 Javier Milei se mostrará con Luis
Barrionuevo y afianza su vínculo con
un sector del sindicalismo. “El sindicalista,
que hasta hace menos de dos meses apoyaba al
kirchnerista Eduardo “Wado” de Pedro en la
carrera presidencial y, después de las PASO,
se comprometió con el libertario, invitó
a varios de sus pares gremiales y a una
decena de empresarios a Parque Norte, donde
se mostrarán juntos por primera vez”. Infobae)
Y es justo aquí donde muchos
encuentran que la existencia
del Teorema de Baglini tiene plena vigencia:
(En 1986, en plena primavera democrática, el
entonces Diputado argentino, Raúl Baglini,
expuso una serie de premisas que se reconocerían
posteriormente como el Teorema de Baglini. Este
teorema consiste principalmente en la siguiente
idea: La responsabilidad de las propuestas
políticas es directamente proporcional a las
chances que se tienen de llegar al poder.)
Es decir, que cuanto más cerca te ves del poder,
más continuista te vuelves. Y justo esta ha
sido la acusación que muchos argentinos han
comenzado a realizar contra ciertos giros de
la Libertad Avanza hacia una cierta moderación.
Digamos que, como dicen por ahí, no es lo
mismo llamar al diablo, que verlo llegar,
y ahora que las puertas de la Casa Rosada
están cada vez más abiertas al arribo de Milei,
la gobernabilidad comienza
a ser un tema prioritario.
(Aquí entonces encontramos dos posibilidades bien
diferentes, una, es que el gabinete libertario
está comenzando a enfriar el exponencial
idealismo manifestado en la campaña de las
pasadas primarias. La otra es considerar
que la inserción de huérfanos políticos,
tanto del kirchnerismo como de Juntos por el
Cambio, en los equipos políticos de Milei,
están generando algunas distorsiones
respecto al ideario libertario.
Esto último podría llegar a representar una
peligrosa paradoja para la ecuación de gobierno
de La Libertad Avanza. Al fin y al cabo, no es
un secreto para nadie que Javier Milei ha logrado
colgar un cartel encima de todos los políticos
argentinos con una palabra clave: Casta.)
Claro que también existe una tercera
posibilidad que explique por qué la
candidatura de Milei podría llegar a
adoptar posiciones menos rupturistas:
Como ya hemos visto, las reformas de
la educación y la sanidad requieren
acuerdos con los gobiernos provinciales y locales,
al tiempo que la nueva doctrina de seguridad
también necesitaría un amplio acuerdo legislativo.
Es exactamente lo mismo que ya se ha
planteado con las reformas económicas:
Milei necesitará a la casta para poder gobernar.
Y eso explica que algunos grandes temas,
incluso los grandes temas estrella, poco a
poco corran el riesgo de terminar enfriándose.
C4 (Carlos Rodríguez se distanció de la
dolarización que plantea Emilio Ocampo:
"No se puede hacer en este momento. Es discutible
el plan de Ocampo, en el pizarrón está perfecto,
el tema es si políticamente el Congreso lo
va a votar y si en la práctica esos activos
el mercado va a considerar que valen algo.
Yo no estoy de acuerdo” Carlos Rodríguez,
referente económico de Javier Milei.)
(3:21 la metodología para
3:25 dolarizar no la tienen cerrada?
3:29 hay varias metodologías, por ejemplo
3:31 esta metodología es la más fácil:
3:33 nosotros nos sentamos con fondos de
3:35 inversión de alto riesgo y están
3:37 dispuestos a poner los treinta mil
3:39 millones de dólares
3:40 (periodista) Pero nadie
quiere prestarle a la Argentina
3:43 pero sígame el argumento)
De momento si podemos decir algo es que la opinión
pública argentina está partida en torno a Milei:
Como podéis ver el 50% de los argentinos
piensan que Argentina mejorará mucho o algo,
al tiempo que el 45% considera que el país
estará peor tras 4 años de Milei como presidente.
Sea como sea, ya lo veis. Más allá de
la dolarización y la reforma económica,
el equipo de Milei también plantea
importantes cambios en materia de Educación,
Sanidad y Seguridad. El problema es
que aquí las propuestas y los posibles
resultados son todavía más difusos. El
nivel de incertidumbre es mucho mayor.
La pregunta que ahora nos podíamos hacer es:
Vale, esto es lo que persigue hacer con la
Argentina… Pero, ¿y de puertas para fuera?
¿Qué pasará con Mercosur, con Brasil, con
China o con las relaciones con Washington?
Pues todo eso y más lo veremos en una
próxima entrega aquí en VisualPolitik
Ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like
y suscribiros a este canal si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto